within 30 minutes the seven of you could
make the internet unusable for the
entire nation is that correct that's
correct actually one of us with just a
few packets if a foreign government was
able to assemble a group of gentlemen
such as yourself paid them large amounts
of money how much damage could they do
your phone systems are down your
electricity's gone your financial
markets let's say that I have taken over
mci's networks uh which would not be a
tremendously difficult thing to do so I
I can watch everything that goes through
this major backbone providers transitory
networks but I can't watch Sprint well
what am I going to do I'll disrupt
Sprint service so that everybody routes
through me now I can learn everything
you're doing I can watch your movements
I can stop your movements I can issue
requests on your behalf number of
systems that can be disrupted is so
great that it would probably wreak a lot
of havoc in the country whether or not
the country can recover from that in an
adequate period of time or defend
against it is is a good question